Can human beings wipe out a species for good?
… … … [ That's wordplay.]
Hey terminators, Julian here for DNews.
When we talk about extinction, most of the
time, it’s a bad thing.
Nobody celebrated when poaching drove the
west african black rhino out of existence,
because they had done nothing to incur the
wrath of humanity besides having a horn on
their face.
So have human beings ever caused an extinction
that would make the most kind-hearted conservationist
bust out the confetti and sing “na na na
na hey hey hey goodbye?”
Has there ever been a good, intentional extinction?
So far it has happened exactly one time.
In 1979 smallpox was officially declared eradicated.
The disease was caused by the variola virus
and existed for over 3,000 years.
It caused raised, red bumps that would fill
with fluid that would turn into pus and 30%
of the people infected died.
In the 20th century it killed some 300 million
people worldwide.
Clearly it was a bad mama-jama, but thanks
to an aggressive global vaccination campaign,
it’s been wiped as far as we know out save
for a few samples that exist in laboratories.
So if people ever ask what good vaccines do;
that.
Nobody got all weepy eyed when variola took
a hike because it wasn’t a valuable part
of its ecosystem like other species we unintentionally
wipe out.
Smallpox only affected humans, so once it’s
gone everybody wins.
Well, except the virus.
After smallpox we’ve come close to eliminating
a few other ailments, but we haven’t gotten
to 100% completion yet.
The next closest species we’ve almost wiped
out (intentionally) is the guinea worm.
The guinea worm is a parasite that’s terrible
in almost every way.
It enters its human host when they drink contaminated
water.
It drills out of their intestines and sets
up shop in the abdominal muscles where it
grows for a few months until it reaches sexual
maturity.
Then the males and females mate, yes, while
still inside of a person, and the smaller
male dies while the female, which can grow
over a meter long, works its way down to the
person’s leg.
After being inside of its human host for over
a year, the female emerges from the leg or
foot and releases an irritant that causes
the wound to burn.
It burns on and off for months, keeping the
infected person from being able to work.
The only way to sooth it is with water, so
when the host sticks their leg in a stagnant
pool, the mother worm vomits out her millions
of embryos and the whole process starts over
again.
Now you may be thinking that if these embryos
are in the water, then something must eat
them, and you’d be right.
They’re often eaten by water fleas.
But they aren’t a valuable link in the food
chain, because they give the fleas the same
treatment we get; the guinea worm burrows
out of their digestive tract and munches on
their insides while it waits for a human to
swallow the flea.
So everything about this worm is horrible,
and there’s no vaccine or drug that kills
it.
The only way to get rid of it is to cut it
out or wait til it pokes its head out and
then reel that sucker around a stick, drawing
it free a couple of centimeters at a time
over the course of weeks.
Efforts to educate people about how it spreads
and provide them with water filters have been
spectacularly successful.
There were over 3 million cases in 1980, in
2015 there were 22, and so far in 2016 there
have been just 12 cases.
The fight’s not over yet, as now the worms
seem to have jumped to dogs to survive, but
if the campaign to end guinea worms in dogs
is as successful as it has been in humans,
maybe in a couple of years humanity will have
wiped 2 species out.
That we meant to anyway.
Can you imagine how long ago the guinea worm
would have gone extinct if it had a valuable
horn?
Humans might be causing a mass extinction
but it’s not the first!
If you want a recap of the 5 previous times
the earth’s slate was almost wiped clean,
Trace has a video on
it here.
After the Guinea worm, what’s the next disease
we should focus on to eliminate it forever?
Malaria?
I don't know...
Tell us in the comments, subscribe for more
and see you guys next time on DNews.